Let's do an example of using
Newton's second law in problem
solving.
In this example, we'll figure
out why riding in an elevator
can give you a weird
sensation of weightlessness
or extra weight, depending on
which way you're accelerating.
So, let's say there's
a person standing
on a scale in the elevator
that's accelerating
upwards with some
acceleration a.
So we want to know
what the scale reads.
First, we need to
really understand
what the scale measures.
The number that it gives you
is related to the normal force
that you are exerting
on the scale.
So, this is a Newton's third law
pair force to the normal force
that the scale exerts on you.
So if we can figure out the
normal force on the person
from the scale, we'll know
what the scale should read.
Now let's set up our
coordinate system.
I'm going to assign the upward
direction to be positive y.
And since the only
forces in this problem
are acting vertically,
I don't need
to define another direction.
I'll pick the system
to be the person.
Now, I'll think about what
we know and what we don't.
Since that person is
standing in the elevator--
not jumping, not
moving otherwise--
they must be
accelerating upwards
with acceleration a, the
acceleration of the elevator.
I also know the
mass of the person.
So now I have one side
of Newton's second law.
Now I need to think about
what vertical forces are
acting on the person.
First, there's the gravitational
force pulling the person down.
This gravitational
force does not
depend on the acceleration
of the elevator,
because the gravitational
interaction is just
between the person
and the earth.
So the force is minus m g.
Finally, I have the normal force
that's holding the person up.
This is the normal force
from the interaction
between the person
and the scale.
And so this is the unknown
quantity that I'd like to know.
Let's look at
Newton's second law.
On the left, I have
f n, the normal force
that I'm interested
in, minus m g,
the gravitational
pull from the earth.
And on the right, I have
m, the person's mass,
times a, the acceleration
of the elevator
and, therefore, the person.
Notice that when the
elevator is accelerating,
the normal force and
the gravitational force
do not have the same magnitude.
That is, they don't cancel out.
So now I can solve
for f n, and I
can find that it's just m
times the quantity, a plus g.
Have you ever noticed that
at the bottom of an elevator
ride, when you're accelerating
upward, you feel heavier?
And at the top when
you're decelerating,
you often feel lighter?
You can see that if
I change a to minus a
in this example, that I'll
get the normal force is
equal to m times g minus a.
And this explains that
feeling of lightness.
It's always good to check
that your answers match
physical intuition.
And I encourage
you to go and play
with elevators and other
physical phenomena around you
while you're going
through this course
to see if your answers
make physical sense.